- So wait, since you're
the baby of the family,
did your brothers or sisters,
did they give you a hard time?
I'm the baby in my family.
- I'm the baby,
like your baby in your
family could get like love.
- No, we...
- I'm the baby of 10 comedians,
so you have to understand
I'm the butt of every joke.
- Yeah, that was my life!
- Every sister almost
killed me in some way.
- Okay, no, wait, what, no, yeah.
- My sister, Devonne,
I accidentally ate a vitamin E pill
and she said, "Marlon, you're gonna die."
I said, "what?"
She goes, "so the only
way you could fix it,
you gotta drink nine
glasses of cold water,
eight glasses of warm water,
and six glasses of hot water."
Girl, I almost drowned. (laughs)
I sitting in the bed with
water spilling out my mouth.
My belly was filled up to here.
She goes, "don't tell mama."
I was like...
- Oh my gosh!
- And then she bribed me with a Tic Tac,
and put that in my mouth
with the water drooling out of my mouth.
I didn't tell mama, but I did almost die.
That was interesting.
- Okay, that was a little more intense.
One of my siblings gave me
chocolate covered dog food
and said it was candy.
(audience laughs)
- That's not bad.
- Honestly, it tasted like chocolate, so.
(laughs)
- Every last sibling has probably
farted on me from the ages of one.
- Did they do the spit thing,
where they suck it back up?
They pin you down, they spit,
and then they suck it back up?
- No, that's gross!
- Exactly!
I'm telling you, do you know that I have
a complete phobia of saliva to this day?
- You need a new family!
- No, he used to pin me down,
and he'd do that spit thing,
and he'd suck it back up.
That happened to anybody?
Thank you!
(audience laughs)
Everyone's family is messed up.
Not just mine, Marlon!
- No, but listen, here's
the beauty, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- I used to tell my brothers
"one day you will be old."
(Kelly laughs)
"And when you on that deathbed,
I'm farting in your mouth."
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- I am Dutch ovening you like...
(laughs) That's amazing.